[Música]
inés manzano abogada experta en derecho
ambiental y sostenibilidad dirige dos
empresas consultoras ambientales creadas
por ella en el 2003 para asesorías
técnicas ambientales y contabilización
de los gases de efecto invernadero
preside el directorio del consejo
empresarial pero el desarrollo
sostenible es cendes organización
mundial que se encuentra en 80 países
preguntas interesantes de este día creo
y se las voy a dejar con ustedes es si
saben que es una ciudad si saben qué
tipo de ciudad ustedes quieren vivir e
imaginémonos la cantidad de
y recursos naturales que necesita una
ciudad para hacer ciudad y ofrecer y si
la pregunta es si sabemos que ciudad
aunque es una ciudad la otra pregunta
sería si ustedes creen que las ciudades
son finitas para siempre y tenemos
algunos casos en la historia en la que
no lo son hay una famosísimo éfeso en el
cual la ciudad dejó de ser ciudad porque
perdió su puerto y así tenemos algunos
otros casos hasta de la vida moderna
por qué pasa esto
usualmente son porque no hemos visto
hacia futuro no tenemos a veces una
visión de sostenibilidad y la
sostenibilidad no es un concepto etéreo
afortunadamente el año pasado tuvimos
algunos eventos importantes
lau datos y con el papá francisco que
hablaba de temas ecológicos pero más
allá de la dignidad humana y tuvimos
también los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible que un poco definían que era
este tema de la sostenibilidad entonces
quedamos de acuerdo en que no era sólo
conservar los pajaritos sino que había
que hacer muchísimo más al respecto y
entonces estaba fin de la pobreza hambre
cero ciudades infraestructura cambio
climático océanos y un poco de cosas
entonces esta foto que uno ve ahí me
dice qué bonita la lo que se ve no el
agua etcétera la ciudad al fondo y lo
verde pero todo eso necesita un
mecanismo interno no solamente de los
recursos naturales sino también una
buena administración pública y unos
excelentes ciudadanos porque tenemos
mucho que hacer al respecto
también tenemos unos unos datos que son
interesantes porque siempre me he
escuchado eso de la migración del campo
a la ciudad
pero vamos a ver datos y esa data a
nivel mundial dice que en el año 2050 en
promedio el 70 por ciento de la
población va a estar en ciudades y eso
es un desafío pero adicionalmente si
ustedes ven una tabla van a ver que hay
dos continentes que todavía no están
plenamente organizados es decir que
todavía hay gente que vive en el campo
asia y áfrica y dos continentes que
pesan por su población pero en el 2050
ya me están diciendo que en promedio
todos vamos a ir hacia las ciudades y
que paso en el ecuador es muy simpático
saber que el ecuador en el año 2015
hasta el año pasado el 69% de la
población ecuatoriana ya estaba en
ciudades y en el 2050 va a ser el 80 por
ciento y estas proyecciones de
crecimiento entonces también nos
volvería deberíamos volvernos a
preguntar qué tipo de ciudad queremos y
también qué tipo de ciudadanos queremos
ser para esa ciudad
en cuanto a las ciudades y su uso de
recursos naturales tenemos que por
ejemplo son las que tienen el 70 por
ciento de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero en el mundo y este
impacto es importante y entre ese 70%
que el transporte que la iluminación de
los edificios que los servicios públicos
para generarlos y para dar los etcétera
y consumen entonces el 2 dos tercios de
la energía mundial es la pregunta
también vuelve a ser buena porque ciudad
es la que queremos que ciudad o que
tenemos que tener en la ciudad para que
haya podamos albergar más gente y más
gente de una manera
entonces también tenemos que el
crecimiento económico ha tenido sus
impactos en los temas ambientales y si
ustedes ven ahí en el transcurso de los
años estamos ya en la década del 2000
para arriba como ha habido una
degradación de ese ambiente por ese
impacto que tenemos en varias cosas
puede ser en la pérdida de biodiversidad
en las emisiones de co2 en la huella
ecológica etcétera etcétera etcétera y
uno va viendo que mientras más vamos
siendo industrializados o más vamos
yendo hacia ciudades va a haber un mayor
impacto a esos recursos naturales que
nos necesitamos para el día a día aunque
no lo creamos lo necesitamos entonces
una definición y esa es una idea que les
propongo y vinimos a la ciudad o qué
tipo de ciudad entonces yo me voy a
hacer una definición de lo que
es una ciudad sostenible y ese es el
tema queremos la sostenibilidad también
en las ciudades no solamente en las
empresas en los productos en las
políticas públicas en el gobierno sino
en la ciudad donde yo soy parte y parte
de eso de ahí es por ejemplo inclusivas
la interna decir que esto es inclusiva
es simpatiquísimo porque inclusive es
mirar a la gente informal al comerciante
informal y tenemos porque encima los
ecuatorianos y alrededor del mundo
también robo hablar del caso de corazón
muy creativos viendo un artista y
ustedes van a ver que exactamente a la
hora haberse anunciado el artista hay
unas camisetas y se venden los city y se
venden las cosas y esa es la creatividad
innata y el emprendedor innato
ecuatoriano entonces el tema de hacer
inclusión inclusive es eso mirarlos y
hacerlos parte de la ciudad no al lado
parte de la ciudad y con el reto que eso
significa seguras la seguridad viene de
dos vías la seguridad tiene que ser esa
física que yo quiero sentir
y que no hayan robos que me sienta
cómoda y la otra es obviamente la
seguridad jurídica en la que las normas
estén bien claras y que si hay dice que
no podemos hacer algo pues el que lo
haga pues tenga su sanción porque
vivimos en unas comunidades y vivimos en
una sociedad idea y competitiva si este
término me encanta porque era el banco
mundial está hablando de ciudades
competitivas pero yo creo que la ciudad
competitiva es una característica de la
ciudad sostenible y la competitividad
tiene que ver de manera importante para
ser sostenible en el tiempo no estamos
hablando de productividad o sea una
ciudad puede ser muy productiva pero no
puede ser competitiva entonces hay una
diferencia entre lo uno y lo otro el
cual yo puedo producir muchísimo pero no
estoy en el mercado y no ofrezco lo que
debería y la gente no se va a sentir
cómoda y no va a venir a la ciudad o no
va a ver un desarrollo porque el
desarrollo de las sociedades usualmente
aunque no lo crean pero pónganse a
pensar pasa en las ciudades en estos
momentos en las ciudades
y de ahí la resiliencia y esto de ser
resilientes es un concepto que dentro de
un país como el nuestro debería de ser
muy importante porque es un país
altamente vulnerable de acuerdo a las
naciones unidas tenemos como 12 12
características de vulnerable
vulnerabilidad
nosotros tenemos 11 la única que no
tenemos es que somos un país al interior
de uno de un continente porque nosotros
estamos en la costa pero en tal caso
cuando las ciudades son resilientes es
porque después de un gran shock que
puede ser que te quede sin no ser el
recurso vital agua sin energía después
de una catástrofe como un terremoto un
tsunami cual es la habilidad de la
ciudad para sap delante y esa habilidad
es la que va a ser que haya una
resiliencia también para adaptarse a los
cambios que hay y después tenemos que
bueno esta es una característica muy
nueva y es una idea también propuesta a
ustedes déjala
es felicidad ser felices y en ese es el
que me voy a detener un poquito más
porque a veces la felicidad la podemos
entender cómo tenemos que estar
riéndonos todo el tiempo pero no ya hay
estudios que se basan en otras cosas en
otros hechos en otros juicios que se van
valorando y la felicidad de acuerdo al
reporte del 2016 de naciones unidas es
una serie de cosas y en resumen es que
hayan virtudes interesantes y qué
virtudes porque encima lo dicen naciones
unidas- las de aristóteles entonces hay
que ir a ver qué es lo que decía
aristóteles con las virtudes y una de
las una de las virtudes que van varias
de las que habla la justicia la
prudencia la templanza me parece
interesante una propuesta de felicidad
para una ciudad que sea para llamarla
sostenible el trabajo decente las
libertades personales muy importantes
que podamos acceder que podamos decidir
por nosotros mismos el buen gobierno
porque en verdad
es el que nos va a dar como yo hablaba
ante un poco de seguridad pero también
el que va a empujar y que va a hacer que
ese crecimiento económico sea canalizado
y los fuertes lazos sociales eso es lo
que hace feliz al mundo de acuerdo
naciones unidas ecuador está en mi
puesto 49 hasta que somos un país
medianamente feliz todavía no llegamos
al top pero estamos entonces creo que
ese concepto de la felicidad es un
concepto de la sostenibilidad de la
sociedad donde de la sociedad que es
parte dentro de una ciudad y también hay
muchas cosas que ya ya salen de este
espectro de características como
hablábamos nos resiliencia etcétera que
es un poco a ver pero y además de eso
que el diseño no el diseño de una ciudad
es muy importante una cosa súper
ordenado como vemos en el esquema de
aquí y otra que no tengamos ni principio
ni fin y puros recovecos y como tenemos
a cinco kilómetros a la redonda los
servicios que necesitamos para nuestras
vidas
de un lado para el otro entonces el
diseño de la ciudad la movilidad el
acceso a materiales a recursos naturales
a servicios básicos etcétera eso ya es
digamos una parte de d
ejecución de actividades pero las
características las hemos visto ya y con
eso quiero retomar a por qué estoy aquí
porque en verdad eso de la ciudad es
sostenible increíble pero en lo que
motiva más hablar de ciudades
sostenibles es porque tenemos unas
ciudades que han pasado por un shock
hablábamos de la resiliencia y tuvimos
un evento de 7.8 el 16 de abril y a los
3 días de esta de este evento con mi
esposo fuimos al lugar de los hechos
porque ellos obviamente éste tenían un
impacto muy fuerte en la empresa y vimos
primero lo que pasaba con la gente de
los trabajadores no cómo estaban ellos y
estaban bien sí que les necesitaban
muchos de ellos no sabían lo que estaba
pasando alrededor de ellos en el ecuador
entero y eso me impresionó es decir
ellos pensaban que estaban solos
y a mí eso me dejó marcaba y dije en
verdad si hay algo que la vida aquí
desde que era chiquita quería hacer era
salvar el mundo y después me fui
caminando porque esto es salvar el mundo
es como como muy etéreo no entonces pues
es valencia pero define de firme y yo
decía quiero salvar el mundo del temas
ambientales y después me dijo hay en
esos temas ambientales cómo vas a hacer
si eres abogada y estaba más preocupado
aquello pero en verdad la definición
hace que tú vayas cortando cortando y
teniendo esta misión en tu vida y creo
que una renovación en la mía ha sido
poder ayudar y poder estar ahí donde
haya gente que necesita que hay un golpe
de aliento y un apoyo o como un pie de
amigo que siempre digo yo pero este
terremoto
entonces motiva a que si yo tanto
hablaba la sostenibilidad de las
ciudades sostenibles que podemos hacer
con eso y me embarco en tocar puertas y
es
hoy en día son más puertas de las que
puedo podría atender en este momento
pero una de esas fue el alcalde de
portoviejo y le dije oiga usted es la
capital de manabí porque primero decidí
que quería que hacer que manabí sea
sostenible pero después dije mejor me
voy por ciudades y al ir por la ciudad
de portoviejo me encontré con un alcalde
muy abierto y con unos funcionarios
públicos
que habían sido tocadas hasta su última
membrana con lo que pasaba porque día a
día están ahí atendiendo a la gente y
estas son algunas de las imágenes que
ustedes tal vez han visto y que
conmueven el uno es el edificio del ies
este y el otro es un poco la zona zero
de portoviejo y ahí hay también unos dos
niños con una sonrisa tan felices pero
están en un albergue entonces cada cosa
que se estaba viendo estamos viendo que
hay una oportunidad para hacer de este
alcaldía esposa de este municipio de
portoviejo una ciudad sostenible y en
estos momentos lo que hicimos fue hacer
para la empresa privada pero no para que
invierta en a lo loco sino que tuvimos
que sentarnos y sentarnos a decir que lo
que ustedes quieren cuál es la propuesta
de valor de portoviejo y esta propuesta
de valor tenía 30 de salud turismo y el
otro es el tema agroindustrial porque se
conocen entonces no todas las ciudades
sostenibles van a tener la misma
propuesta de valor y este es un poco
como el diagrama de lo que hacemos
semana a semana en nuestras reuniones y
en la cual lo que hacemos es un poco
prestar las neuronas de los empresarios
para saber si lo que estamos viendo hace
atractivo para la competitividad para
las inversiones a la ciudad y sobre todo
nos hemos enfocado y eso aquí lo que les
pongo en un ejemplo pero nos hemos
enfocado en la gente en lo que piensa en
la gente en lo que la gente necesita y
la que la gente obviamente
está muy es una resiliencia también
humana la que vemos y sobre todo a mí me
ha impresionado ver la característica de
manabí y voy a decir en general y sobre
todo de portoviejo en el cual quieren
salir adelante y cuando alguien ama su
ciudad es un buen paso para saber que
hay una persona que encontró la
felicidad y que puede ser una para ese
motivo y ese motorcito para una ciudad
sostenible hoy en día estamos ya en el
compact of mayors con la ciudad de
portoviejo y tengo dos ciudades más que
también quieren serlo pero vamos a ir
paso a paso que es el compact major se
es una organización digamos este mundial
tiene siete mil ciudades
portoviejo fue más que bienvenida por su
visión por sus ganas de hacer las cosas
está dirigida por naciones unidas y
otras otros
otras personas como alcaldes como el de
nueva york que era michael bloomberg y
el otro día estaba viendo a jaime lerner
que fue alcalde de curitiba en brasil y
decía que cualquier ciudad si tiene
algunas características y está sabe a
dónde va en tres años puede levantarse y
eso me parece extraordinario porque es
una esperanza de alguien que ha estado
es bueno fue alcalde de curitiba y es
ahora asesora a nivel mundial de
ciudades que sabe lo difícil que es
sacar adelante a las ciudades y quiero
terminar y antes de tiempo para que
sepan quiero terminar invitándolos a que
pensemos otra vez en esto de las
ciudades sostenibles a que pensemos en
la gente que está en puerto viejo a que
pensemos que definamos nuestra visión en
la vida y tengamos esta solidaridad a
que seamos parte de sociedades con
cambios importantes y que podamos llevar
de la mano temas tan vitales como la
ciudad sostenible a esos lugares
necesitando para volver a sacarlos
adelante y que yo tengo la fe porque es
una es una sociedad humana va muy
pujante muy muy
sabe y se conoce de lo que es capaz de
hacer y creo que una de las cosas más
lindas yo ya que tengo una aplicación
entonces agua y me puso y sé que soy muy
creativa no sé si tengo una aplicación y
dije bueno voy a hacerla y saqué este
corazón y me disfrazado de ese corazón
desde el primer momento en que tuve el
contacto con manabí porque creo que es
una es una excelente comunidad de la
cual todos nosotros podemos aprender y
lo que quiero es exactamente lo mismo
pase con ustedes enamorarse de un
proyecto enamorarse de una visión
enamorarse de una ciudad y poder
ayudarla haciendo parte de esa comunidad
sostenible gracias
[Aplausos]